if you need one more reason to be on
your phone in public we got one for you
Pokemon go yes you've heard of it
Nintendo's latest mobile game in just
one week it has amassed millions of
users all running around finding
capturing and battling fantastical
creatures people have lost their damn
minds over this game it's so popular
that it has more daily active users and
Twitter the app claimed the top spot on
iTunes and in the google play store in
just one short week which means more
people are catching pokemon then dates
on tinder so what is it about this game
that has so many people so out of their
skulls it's pretty clever instead of
playing in a fictional location pokemon
go users travel around their actual
physical world using their phones is
viewports to a fantasy land superimposed
on top of it find water pokemon on the
shore grass pokemon in the field and
rare powerful pokemon in special or
unique locations throughout the city
using augmented reality which accesses
the outward facing camera on your
smartphone the game shows Pokemon
waiting to be captured as if they've
appeared in front of your phone that
interaction with the world around us is
what has driven so many users to explore
cities and play meet each other and
socializing ways that no mobile game has
ever done before and if you think it's
just your neighborhood it's not this
game is so successful that Nintendo
stock price has soared enough to add
seven and a half billion dollars to the
company's valuation that's enough money
to catch them all
you